como veíamos habló el presidente de
hasan rohan y que acusó a israel de
estar detrás de esto y hablaba también
de esa retaliación de la que ha hablado
todos los más importantes integrantes de
la república islámica incluido el líder
supremo de la revolución que esta mañana
en un tuit también hablaba de la
retaliación pero hay una cosa importante
de la que se habla y es hacerlo en su
momento varios comandantes de las
fuerzas revolucionarias de los guardias
revolucionarios han venido advirtiendo
de que desde israelí otros enemigos de
irán se está tratando de presionar al
país hacia una guerra antes de la
partida del presidente donald trump por
eso decía el presidente roja me es
importante responder en el debido
momento y no dejarse presionar a
llevarlo a algo mayor